month of the Muslim calendar
historically it's the month during which
Allah started telling the Prophet
Muhammad the divine verses that would
eventually be written down as the Quran
but I found a very very profound bonuses
in surah Baqarah I'm gonna finish with
this it's sort of a kind of worse
[Music]
- Angela
so high level feed the power
this journey this road that I travel on
it all seems crazy over the years I
picked up thousands of Tagalongs
inspired by my story from a tree for now
where my clothes had holes in them
I'm afro is picky - the night east
maschino i'm versace
ice no laces inner Archie's new
millennium a ceremony come want me to
write better care to bother the sisters
and dear friends welcome to this video
before I start with a piece I'll also go
to Allah the most merciful the most
trust or praises growing bathrooms him I
came across a very funny cute video and
I mean cooing the content is just like
melts your heart when you see it we're
gonna come through it was actually quite
funny it's of a non Muslim trying
fasting for the first time it's a form
in the video we're going to react to it
but it's there's some very important
lessons to be learned of what he does
yeah along that was the ninth month of
the Muslim calendar historically it's
the month during which Allah's started
telling the Prophet Muhammad the divine
verses that would eventually be written
down as the Quran the central text of
Islam to observe Ramadan all adult
Muslims are required to fast every day
from sunrise to sunset so it's like lint
except instead of giving up one thing
like chocolate you give up everything
for an entire month
at least during the daylight at night
you stop face their work which is sad to
me to be stuff in our face anyways it's
home to one of the largest populations
of Arab Americans in the country the
family I hung out with during Ramadan
were lebanese american so this is Thomas
Morton ok please he's the one who's
trying out yeah watch what he does there
slang as accordingly Lebanese Michigan
Arabic slang first gonna do or rinse the
first word is uh what do what do you is
a kind of a ritual cleansing you do
before you pray as a Muslim it's also a
cleansing you do if you go into a mosque
do anything kind of like holy or all
oriented it's a way of cleaning yourself
especially if you have broken wind
urinated or
had sex anytime since your last prayer
yes sir
hope it doesn't confuse that with you do
some kind of magic mm Jim I'm sorry
flopping up you'd be nice
that would require you to redo it those
being urinating easy number two got it
breaking wind really yes yes a break
when you have to redo you always use
your right hand touch the water and that
doesn't come from the Quran per se but
Arabic culture in which people
customarily wipe their ass the left hand
are used to and so the left hand is
considered unclean and small from the
Sun now say it's monsoon the kind of
thing you used to end
[Music]
[Music]
you know you notice yeah what he says we
go tonight
hey I'm Thomas so you can see that it's
always this funny yeah it's funny not in
a mocking way in a like you know I don't
want to use that you know it's just sort
of you know and it's such an innocent
way innocently that's the way yeah and
because hey I hate a lot it's Thomas
yeah now this links to perfect ayah
which I know and look at the iron before
it it's probably find it connects very
good day over this way I found hey I've
got eyes Thomas just working on figuring
out this whole Islam thing yeah so you
can see it genuinely like look at me try
to understand it if you have any
pointers that could help me especially
with the fasting located here like it's
basically looking for guidance that's
asking for patents yeah you're literally
asking for guidance
yeah I'm we don't know a sentence I
would take it as you know to ask a
scientist in innocent ways it's a bit
funny but it's it's amazing yeah if you
have any points that could help me
especially with the fasting it's kind of
tough being honest with your Lord yet
it's tough and that's how it's gonna be
in life there's gonna be tests are gonna
be tough but I guess that's the point is
so he said help me out in its it's quite
profound he's saying all along
yeah it's hard what I'm doing by help me
feel and that's what it is you're gonna
be tested stop people think we shouldn't
be tested uh i'ma go for so much trials
are you going to go for showers but ask
a lot to make it easy yeah
and we hope this goes your
be like it and I love this thanks Thomas
it's like right in the letter table now
let's go to this for us I found a very
very profound bonuses in surah Baqarah
I'm gonna finish with this in surah
Baqarah verse 186 because I knew this
ayah but it's called up very profound so
in this ayah it says when My servants
asked about me
yeah ask about me then tell them that I
am near I respond to the call of the one
who prays to me to me so they should
respond to me and a faith in me so that
they may they may be on the right path
right now this is very profound cause if
you go to verse one eight five yeah if
you can see because he's doing this what
in Ramadan the verse is this is couple
of is back on for 185 to 187 yeah it's a
valid and the month of Ramadhan is the
one in which the Quran was revealed as
guidance for mankind and as clear signs
that show the right way and distinguish
between right and wrong so those of you
who witnessed a month must fast in it
but the one who is sick or is in a
journey should fast as much as from the
other dates as he missed Allah intends
to provide ease for you and there's not
intend to create hardship for you all
this is that you may complete the number
of fast as prescribed and proclaim the
takbir of Allah for having guided you
and so that he may be grateful and then
the following verse goes when my
servants ask you about me then tell them
that I am near I respond to the call of
the one he he placed me alone not the
Jesus not the Muhammad peace be upon
them not in this kind were to grab that
person so they should respond to me and
have faith in me so that they made me on
the right path that is profound yeah yes
so as you can see so even though here
the word is used a body like my servants
so okay we're talking about someone what
if someone is not a Muslim but the
genuine asking are there's all
discussion on that so you can see here
how that verse span over because he's
asked him directly to Allah he's not a
Muslim but he's asking and that reminds
me if if Thomas is watching this if it
somehow you know from Thomas my version
is Thomas you know what you've did there
is usually we assume that you're genuine
and if you are you allow or guide you
because you've genuine you ask for
kindness and we ask every person who's
looking into Islam to do this because
this is a covenant between you in the
road all la guiding if you are that if
this
is the truth tightening and Allah will
send you guidance and science menace
upon you to take them or reject them
brothers and sisters I found that
amazing I found it very any sweet to see
and his innocence and his ASCII I'm
saying thanks Thomas you know as a
non-muslim trying his best to connect
it's all of us upon Allah Tala Thomas if
there's any question you asked to come
across this video if any of you guys
know his name so ever Thomas I'm here
for if there's any question you want to
ask dude us please bone sister Sephora
share that with you til next time we
also find alternative guide us keep us
honest era thumb stuck in sha Allah make
us among those who are on the haka and I
have good anything do next time a
ceremony from what I hear this journey
this road that I travel on it all seems
crazy over the years I picked up
thousands the Tagalongs inspired by my
story from a juvenile where my clothes
had holes in them I'm afro is picky to
the night east maschino and Versace it's
no Lacey's inner Archie's new millennium
living this life like we're living it
twice alive in the day you can die by
the night I know I just wanted to die
when it's right but how will I know when
it's not in my sight as a young death
never seems so close I don't know when
I'm going but I hope that angels close
by education never mentions almost
everything came from
what types of met the madness
you